I'm just a bajillion things happening at
about an hour ago I was like whoa why
aren't we doing a live stream because
the tour went on sale today and we
should probably do a live stream and
everyone kind of looked at me and was
like oh yes let's do a live stream that
sounds fun anyway here we are we're
doing a live stream a couple things to
tell you so first off the main reason
we're doing this so my first book
don't burn this book comes out on April
28th we've done us seriously not we
actually I should point at you you good
people have done an absolutely freaking
amazing job of support for us already
we've sold thousands and thousands of
copies of the book already which is
which is just awesome the day that we
announce the pre-sale which was back in
August which already seems like a
lifetime ago we hit number three on
Amazon sales list a lot a lot of good
stuffs happening I've been signing book
plates for people and all that good
stuff but as of today the tour don't
burn this book tour don't burn this book
tour is tickets are available for
pre-sale so the link first off the link
to buy tickets now this is an American
tour so far we're gonna add a European
tour we're adding Canada we're gonna do
some stuff in Australia I think Israel a
few other places we're working all that
stuff but right now we've got 17 stops
starting on April 28th and then
throughout May in the United States
we're launching in my original hometown
of New York City at the Gramercy Theatre
on April 28th we're in Philly in the
next night we're gonna we have three
stops Dallas Houston and San Antonio and
Texas Colorado Springs we're doin
Cincinnati Cleveland we're doing Seattle
Portland we're bouncing all over the
country I'm super psyched to get out
there we're doing mostly about
thousand-seat theaters I want to sell
out every freaking one of these things I
want to meet as many of you guys as
possible I want to shake your hands I
want to hear your stories of political
evolution or whatever it is however it
is that I I came into your life it's
just the last couple years have been
just absolutely incredible and and
validating and verifying that I'm doing
the right thing with my life it's it's
pretty cool so I can't wait to just get
back out on tour you know I did about
120 stops in a year in 2019 or 2020 19
geez it was mostly 2018 a little bit
into 2019 with Jordan Peterson and we
did about 20 countries and it was
incredible and just to be a part of that
magic and I assure you I was just a
small part of that magic but just to
meet so many of you guys and see the
energy around all of this stuff so I'm
super psyched so here's what we're gonna
do first off the presale is today
through tomorrow and then they go on
regular sales so if you're watching this
right now you're the first people that
can get the tickets so the link is in
the description down below and you can
go to Live Nation calm and you'll click
the link there you have to enter the
code so low like Han Solo solo2 get
presale tickets you can't do it without
the code so if you click that link you
press you enter the code so low you can
get tickets real quick I'm gonna rifle
off all of the cities for you I'm super
psyched about this Tuesday April 28th
we're at the Gramercy Theatre in New
York Wednesday April 29th we're at the
theater of the Living Arts in
Philadelphia Pennsylvania on May 3rd
we're at the House of Blues in Dallas oh
and I should tell you guys a special
guest will join me for every show so the
way we're gonna do the the format for
these and I think it'll probably change
a little bit on the fly is that I'm
gonna give about an hour talk and then
I'm gonna take a local person usually a
local person and bring them on stage to
do a Q&A with me after we're will take
questions from you guys and as I do it
all of my college events and every
public speaking event that I've done in
the past couple years if you disagree
with me you come to the line first I
will do a moderated Q&A with a special
guest so I'm not announcing all of them
right now but I will tell you because
we're still trying to work some
logistics that for the Dallas show on
May 3rd Glenn Beck will be joining me on
stage then on May 4th were in Houston at
the House of Blues on May 5th were in
San Antonio at the Aztec theater on May
7th were in Cincinnati Ohio at Bogart's
on May 8th were at the House of Blues in
Cleveland May ninth we're at the old
National Center in Indianapolis on May
10th we're at the varsity theater in
Minneapolis on May 11th we're at the
Monroe live in Grand Rapids Michigan
Grand Rapids by the way I cannot wait to
go back to Grand
Rapids that might have been the best
show we did with Jordan there I don't
know what is going on in Grand Rapids
Michigan but you people are on something
I the ones that stand out in my mind
that one Orlando in Miami the Florida
shows were incredible and by the way we
don't have any Florida show set yet
we're working on a whole florida tour I
would just spent the last 10 days down
in Florida you might be able to tell by
the little tan here and I met so many
people in Florida so I we're gonna do
like a whole separate Florida thing
there's something good happening down in
Florida with Florida man so I'm looking
forward to getting back to Grand Rapids
we are on may 12th
we're in Detroit at st. Andrews Hall and
then we are at the Palace of Fine Arts
in San Francisco I will download the
poop app before I get there because they
don't want to step in poop before you do
a big show we're at the Neptune theatre
that was May 19 San Francisco May 20th
at the Neptune Theatre in Seattle
Washington and we're at Revolution Hall
in Portland Oregon right in the home the
heart of an Tifa city that's May 21st
Revolution Hall Portland Oregon for that
one peter Bogosian whoo you guys know my
good buddy and many-time Reuben report
guests will be joining me oh and I
should have mentioned that for the
Silver Springs show which is really the
the DC show and we're doing that one
where'd we go here Silver Springs where
Silver Springs on here somebody get me
that Silver Springs date Wade yeah I
think it may be April 30th where are we
somebody will get me the I think there's
an April 30th Silver Springs that got
cut off on my paper here pretty sure
it's April 30th Silver Springs Christina
Hoff Sommers is gonna join me for that
one so we're gonna add in different
people throughout the tour I'm gonna try
to find people that are local but we'll
see anyway they tickets are on sale
they're at Ticketmaster the Live Nation
link is right down below you got to use
code solo we'll do book signings meet
and greets I'm gonna do special chats
with people after the show if you by
certain level tickets all that good
stuff and on top of everything else
because we give here just like Bernie
Sanders we give to you here at the Rubin
report if you buy tickets today for any
show no matter how many tickets you buy
you buy one you buy 100 will give you
free one-month access if you're a new
subscriber at Rubin report.com so all
you gotta do is buy a ticket wherever
you want to buy the ticket forward your
receipt to support at Rubin report calm
and we're gonna give you a free
one-month access to Rubin report calm
and there's a ton going on over there by
the way guys we've built out a really
awesome community and I'm so proud of
what's going on there there's no BOTS
there's no trolls there's cool
interesting people actually having
discussions about things and then on top
of that you get ad free video you get ad
free podcast by the way as you most of
you know this is the Reuben report
community is the first project of locals
calm that is my tech company that I
built because I didn't want to just
complain about big tech I wanted to
start something so we got some
investment we built out an awesome tech
company I'm going to San Francisco as I
said to to raise some funds we have
major major people coming on board this
thing we have at least I can't I can't
announce anybody yet well we have a
couple people you know about Bridgette
fat Izzie and michael malice is on there
and carpe diem is on there too we got a
whole bunch of people but we have one
person that we're announcing in the next
two weeks that is an absolute internet
game-changer so we're fixed in the
Internet we've got a whole bunch of
other people on there so again right now
you click that link buy a ticket any of
the 17 stops if you're a new subscriber
we're gonna give you a month free of
Reuben report.com and then what I said I
would do is that Silver Spring my people
are telling me it's not silver springs
thank you
Silver Spring not silver springs
apparently that's a completely other
place or there's just one spring there
so Silver Spring that is the place and
I'm just really again I'm just super
psyched to get back out on the road like
I really do people always would ask me
during the tour with Jordan it's like we
did all this hundred some-odd stop thing
and we're bouncing between you know
norway and sweden and denmark and do UK
here there the other thing and just
bouncing across different cities in
different countries and the whole thing
and people would ask are you tired or
whatever and it was like there were
moments where i guess I was a little
tired or I slept on a plane but I loved
every second of it it was really one of
the best years of my life it's like
going to places that I had never been
you know I'd never been to Dublin in
Ireland going and meeting these people
who seemingly come from completely
different walks of life and that someone
in Dublin is thinking the same thing as
someone in Stockholm who's thinking the
same thing as someone in Kansas City
who's thinking the same thing as someone
in
Toronto and then all coming together
about it is pretty awesome and the other
thing that I would always talk about in
the tour with Jordan I would always
start the shows with something like this
you know there'd be like 3,000 people in
a theater and I would always tell
everybody you know take a moment guys
look around this room you know most of
us you watch these shows like you
watching this right now whether you're
watching on your your iPhone or your
iPad or your Apple TV or your laptop
whatever it is most likely you're
watching this solo right you might be
watching with a boyfriend or a
girlfriend or a prostitute I don't know
what you're doing but you're not
watching with a whole group of people
usually these are these are pretty solo
direct conversations which is why I
always talk try to talk directly to the
camera to you with this stuff because
that's sort of how we're doing this
right and when I would do the shows with
Jordan and there'd be three thousand
sometimes one of the shows in was
Melbourne Australia six thousand people
there I would say look around this room
guys like there are all sorts of other
people that look all sorts of different
ways right the the diversity that the
Left cares about they were different
colors and they were different genders
and different sexualities all the
nonsense that free-minded clear-thinking
people just absolutely don't care about
but say look around this room there are
other good people out there and you
don't know if they're actually in your
office or on the subway with you or at
work with you or at the playground with
your kids or whatever else it is so
that's what I want out of this tour I
want to bring people together do the VIP
meet and greets after you know one of
the nights in one one of the best nights
of the the Jordan tour was in Stockholm
I would do orden would do his
meet-and-greet and he'd get hundreds of
people doing it and we would do a pretty
much an impromptu meet-and-greet for me
that was just sold that day sometimes
just with him right after the show you
know fifty or hundred people would come
the Stockholm one was so incredible the
room was so packed with a hundred people
in this this pretty tight room that I
said you know what let's get out of here
guys and let's find a bar and we
basically hundred people just took over
a bar in Stockholm it was awesome we did
something like that in Amsterdam - there
was a little little of that but I'm
looking forward to just getting out
there and meeting you guys and taking
questions and shaking hands and the
whole thing so I'll do one more promo
thing and then by the way I'm gonna do a
Q&A right now alive ask me anything for
subscribers at Rubin report.com so if
you want to ask me a question
right now buy a ticket to the tour
forward your receipt over to support at
Rubin report comm we're gonna give you
free access for a month to check it out
and maybe you'll stick around maybe you
won't I hope you will and then going
forward you can pay you basically pay
whatever you want that's the way we're
doing it and by having just a little bit
of a paywall by the way we've gotten rid
of the bots and the trolls no trolls in
there and that's why I think what we're
doing with locals by the way is so cool
because every all the people were
building communities for you set your
own rules in your community so for
example I have a pretty what I would say
is a liberal set of rules in my
community as far as speech you can
basically say what you want you can't
break the laws of the United States you
can't post porn but pretty much beyond
that you can do whatever you want but if
you're a relentless dick I think that's
the way I rephrase it in the rules but
then we're gonna boot yet I've only had
to boot one person but it's like by the
way if you get booted from my local you
could still be in British Bridgette fat
Aziz you can still be in Michael palaces
oh I should have mentioned Michael
malice before you can be in these other
people things so there's no deep
platforming it's the same way you want
free speech say on the street right but
you don't invite everybody into your
house to say whatever they want to you
so I think there's a new more mature way
that we can treat the Internet and
that's what I'm one of the things that
I'm gonna be obviously talking about a
lot about in the tour it's one of the
things that the book is about and many
other things
ok so let's let's do a little Q&A right
now at the same time a lot of questions
are rolling in here we go oh well how
are you and David holding up after Emma
so well thanks for asking did not expect
that to be the first question we're good
basically so for those of you that that
may not know or didn't see the video we
posted a couple weeks ago so our 16 year
old dog Emma we let her move on to the
doggie heaven in the sky it was two
weeks ago yesterday or the day before
two weeks ago on Monday sixteen years
old you know I know everybody says oh
they're dogs the special law and they're
dogs the best in that whole thing but
this dog was was truly truly special and
in many ways she was like my she would
you know I have a companion in life but
I had this other companion that I had
been with for fourteen of her years she
was a rescue from hurricane
Catrina I know how do you know the story
she gave birth during the hurricane they
found her in a box the puppies were
basically healthy she was deathly ill
they found her at st. Bernard's parish
one of her children one of her puppies
got named Bernard and then I posted this
long Twitter thread about Emma about a
year ago and she got sick she had
bladder cancer and then through that
Twitter thread I was able to reconnect
with the woman that owned Bernard 14
years later and Bernard came here a
couple times to our house mo was
basically too old to travel at that
point but Emma got reconnected with her
son Bernard 14 years later and Bernards
an old-timer he's 14 now but we got them
together a bunch and she was just a
gorgeous great dog if you look in our
recent videos there's a video that I
took of her the day before we let her go
just munching down on a bone and we we
just we had a great three-day weekend
with her before we just basically sat
outside for three straight days we gave
her every bone every we cooked or you
know grass-fed ribeye is the last thing
that we did for her was we would David
had always wanted to do this we he
cooked a whole chicken okay picture a
whole chicken cooked it and we just put
it on the floor for her this is about an
hour before we let her go and we just
let her tear through it there's some
videos on Twitter that I posted about it
but sheet aired through that thing and
and then it was it was time to go and
you know it sucks it's like she was 16
she had she had life and her still she
was on steroids at the end just they
just you know that's it's the last thing
you could do basically for a dog and
often for humans to to just juice the
system one more time to make that last
bit of time good and we could have
probably strung it along a little bit
longer but she did have it she had a
pretty large tumor in her bladder and so
basically she felt like she had to pee
all the time so she was she was peeing
everywhere our itis was bad she was
having trouble getting up so sometimes
she was peeing in bed and the rest of it
and I just didn't want it to end or we
didn't want it to end just horrific ly
you know and the thing is with steroids
it works for a while but then when it
turns it's it's pretty bad at once and I
didn't just want her to collapse or just
you know drop one day or whatever it is
so we gave her the chicken we sat with
her for a while
we cried we did everything you do and
and someone came to the house I was a
woman who was highly recommended she
could not have been better and we got to
say our goodbyes and and that's it I
will tell you one other crazy thing
about Emma
that night so obviously was an
incredibly emotional weekend day you
know just crying all day long and and by
the way I was I had been posting these
videos and pictures of Emma and one of
the videos that I posted on Twitter got
like a million views and just the
endless love pouring in all day which is
one of the reasons that doing this
despite all the hate that I get is worth
it because you get a whole lot of love
too and it's mostly love actually
although often you end up paying
attention to the hate more but you know
just a super emotional day and we we did
it at about 7 p.m. and we let her go and
they took her and you know we're just
crying messes and you know the house was
messed it was chicken all over the floor
I mean was the whole thing anyway we
kind of clean ourselves up we had a
little light Nair and then at about
10:30 we're going to bed and David was
in the bathroom brushing his teeth and I
was standing in the bedroom and I'm just
kind of standing there and all the
lights in the house were off except in
the bedroom because we were going to bed
and then suddenly all the lights in the
house turned on every single light in
every single room turned on what the
hell that what's that I said David why
did you turn the lights on he said what
are you talking about I thought you
turned the lights on and every single
light in the house was on I don't know
you know some people you depends what
you believe in right weird things happen
so did mo was that like her little
message to us who knows and then then
one other thing is two days later we
happen to walk by this pet adoption
place near us and I said how is just
going David didn't really want to go in
but I was like I was just not to not to
adopt anybody right now but just let's
just go in look we walk in there there
one dog they call it a red healer which
is a type of Australian Cattle Dog which
is part of what Emma was I see the dog
you know there's like I don't know 30 40
dogs in a big pen the dog the second I
open the door the dog is looking at me
and it's just got these same eyes as
Emma kind of looks all out like Emma and
then we're standing there outside of the
pen and the pen it's probably a good
like I don't know maybe 4 feet high
three and a half four feet high up to
here and I'm talking to the adoption
I'm telling him about Emma and
everything and that were well consider
getting a dog at some point the dog
jumps out of the pen
literally perches I mean I'm talking the
the ledge on this thing was like five
six inches like that perches right next
to me sits there just start staring at
me so I don't know if that's Emma
talking through me or but yada yada yada
I post a picture of that then a
gajillion people are telling me that
that was the sign and the dog wants me
to adopt it and the dogs chooses you and
the whole thing wery relieving the next
day for ten days so we couldn't do it
and I have been told since that the dog
got adopted by a great family so it's
all good what the hell am i doin here
besides talking about dogs people don't
burn this book tour it has begun as of
today the pre-sale the link for Live
Nation is right down below seventeen
stops in the US were kicking off in New
York City at the Gramercy Theatre we'll
have a special guest on that one I can't
just announce it just yet but it's gonna
be somebody good I promise you that in
my hometown of New York City we're in
Philly the next night i rifled off all
the cities every night i'll do about an
hour talk well we'll do a moderated Q&A
with with somebody that you know and
love from the internet from the show
from my from my garage here a different
person in every city and as I said if
you buy a ticket today and you forward
your ticket just forward your receipt to
support at Rubin report calm we'll give
you one month free access to the Rubin
report community where you can get add
free video podcasts you can communicate
with other fan members we here at locals
which is the company that I'm starting
to save the internet because the
Internet is in a real freaking bind
right now and everybody complains about
it and says government help me help me
help me I said well you know what we're
not gonna do that we're gonna actually
build it ourselves so we built something
really cool at Rubin report calm by the
way there's an iOS app just search Rubin
report or going to Google play's there'd
Rubin report and these are the
communities that we're building for all
sorts of people so that they can create
their own network so they can own their
own content so that they can own user
data so that big tech doesn't own the
user data you actually own it so we got
a ton of great things happen and I'm
going to San Francisco on tomorrow to
have a couple days of meetings up there
lots of good stuff happening okay Dave
do you go off the grid every time you're
on vacation or only in August
so you guys know I do this off-the-grid
August thing which I've done three years
in a row literally no phone no
television no news no newspaper no
nothing do not have political
conversations with people no nothing I
did it as a test the first year and it
was so great I was like I'm gonna do it
again and then last year I was like yeah
I'm really gonna do it now people have
started to join me in doing it you know
you realize how we are so connected
we're endlessly connected the thing that
I miss the most is not email and it's
not I assure you it's not Twitter and
Instagram and the rest of it the thing
that I miss most is I have a really
really bad sense of direction so for me
to be wandering around without Google
Maps could be kind of dangerous but I
managed to do it the one thing that I do
in my car has GPS built-in so I still
was using technology for something but
to truly be off technology like no
lights no nothing I don't know maybe
I'll do that this August we'll see but
when I normally you know I try to go off
the grid on the weekends I'm still using
my phone and I'm working and I'm
responding to things and that sort of
thing but that the weekends are more
just no social media generally when I
take a vacation so I was just in Florida
for about a week with my folks and my
brother and sister and all their kids
and we jam ourselves into a two-bedroom
apartment thirteen screaming people and
it's craziness for a week and we're
basically sleeping like Willy Wonka's
grandparents we watch Willy Wonka by the
way which is just such a freaking great
movie I'm talking about gene Wilder or
not not the other guy I don't I don't go
through it like I was working
fortunately these days I could sit on
the beach and actually respond to a
zillion emails and a whole bunch of
other stuff but I really recommend you
guys try it you know if you can't do
both days of the weekend try Saturdays
actually I don't want to give too much
about the book away before the book
comes out obviously but chapter 10 in
the book is about this sort of thing how
we need the Internet we live in this
information age we're all super
connected all of these things and it's
all great and it often feels really bad
because as I said before you sort of
focus on the bad things more than the
good things but there's something
absolutely freaking incredible here
right like we're able to talk about
ideas we were able to communicate and
make each other laugh and cry and share
good and bad and all those things
through this
Sheen right through me staring into this
camera and you having the Internet and
hopefully YouTube not crushing us and
the algorithm too bad and the rest of it
it's all absolutely incredible I mean
it's it's quite literally mind-blowing
from what someone would have thought was
possible 20 years ago and it's also
important though to step away from it
and have some rules around it not let it
rule your life because I find actually
that there are moments where like you
know something will be happening on
Twitter or getting a lot of hate or
whatever is happening and then it's like
before you know it two hours have gone
by and you're just scrolling this one
you know what's going on then you get
off you get off it you put it aside but
your brain is still and you're with real
people and it's like it's hard to just
kind of Center yourself and be present
so it's one of the the tools that I've
used which is just disconnecting
sometimes to stay sane and it's and it's
basically been working I think I think
so so that's pretty good alright one
more time guys quick reset the link is
right down below
don't burn this book 17 us stop starting
April 28th use code solo we're gonna be
in Houston San Antonio Dallas Seattle
Portland Cincinnati Cleveland Grand
Rapids Denver New York whole bunch of
other cities anyone that buys a ticket
today
one ticket two tickets a hundred tickets
whatever you do and you can get VIP
seats you can get seats right up front
you can do the meet and greet whatever
you want to do you get seats in the back
wherever you want to go and we I think
our prices are very fair I fought to get
our prices to be a little bit lower than
they would have been cuz I want as many
people to be able to be there as
possible if you sign up today and you
email that receipt support a truman
report com we're gonna give you a month
free at Reuben report.com
and you can check out the Reuben report
community and get ad free video and all
the rest of it and everything else and a
quick reminder that a special guest will
join me for each show right now we've
got Peter bagozzi and joining me in
Portland we've got Christina Hoff
Sommers joining me in Silver Spring not
Silver Springs Silver Spring Maryland
that's the DC show and who's the other
guy and where are they joining me
it was Christina thank you and Glenn
Beck on May 3rd I believe that's in
Dallas
thank you very much Ellen ok here we go
I ordered the book months ago when's
will when will the book ship so if you
ordered the book on on Amazon or on
Barnes & Noble or anywhere else you will
get the book on April 28th that's the
day the book comes out who's the guests
for Grand Rapids Michigan also should we
ask questions here or on YouTube well
you asked me in the app that's why I saw
it here because we're only taking
questions on the app we don't do YouTube
livestream comments anymore it's a
cesspool of insanity and lunacy and
that's what I mean about a sort of more
mature calm or cooler more decent
internet I'm not against free speech you
can say whatever you want but most
people don't invite everyone into their
home to say whatever they want what I
built at Rubin report calm through
locals is my digital home and that's
what I want to build for other creators
and then other creators can figure out
who they want to associate with and who
they want to share their communities
with it's actually super cool the way
we've done this and I think we've solved
about 95% of the problems for 95% of the
creators so with that in mind we don't
do the use YouTube super chat anymore or
any of that nonsense
first off YouTube takes like 40 percent
of the money to do nothing so that
doesn't seem very fair to me but also
it's just it's just a bunch of hateful
trolls and Nazi frogs and a bunch of
weirdos so literally you pay what you
want at Rubin report com
and you can be involved in this
conversation as you were right here I
don't know who the guest is in Cedar
Rapids yet you know sorry Cedar Rapids
Grand Rapids Michigan what I'm trying to
do is pick people that are local to each
place so Glen back in Dallas obviously
Peter Bogosian lives up in Portland
christina hoff sommers lives in DC so we
got her at Silver Spring and I'm just
looking through I have obviously plenty
of people in New York plenty of people
to choose from in San Francisco I'm
gonna fly some people in I think I know
who I'm gonna use in Minnesota we're
gonna figure it out but actually if
you're part of Rubin report calm and you
put in the comment who you want to see
at each at each city stop with me we'll
see if we can snag them so there you go
do it anything live for the night of
Super Tuesday would be great night to
sit around and talk about a lot of
different stuff as the night unfolds yes
we are doing something live we have
never done this before I'm glad you're
asking so Super Tuesday I'm gonna do a
live stream like this but we are going
to do our first ever live Skype call and
show you guys not pundits not talk
getting heads not talking pundit heads
or anything like that you guys will call
in live via Skype and we'll talk it out
so it's gonna be quite a night there was
no reason to watch the nonsense on CNN
the overproduced pundit Palooza of all
people who you know pontificate and get
everything wrong every time before every
year before what we're gonna do though
is I'm not just taking Skype calls from
anybody because I'm a glutton for
punishment but not that much punishment
you got to be a member at Rubin report
calm and how do you become a member well
do you buy a tour ticket right now we're
gonna give you a membership for the
month absolutely free if you forward
that receipt to support at Rubin report
calm and we'll just I can actually Skype
in now we can Skype in I think for
people at once for including me we're
gonna Skype in you guys you can be in
America you can be in Europe you can be
in the Middle East wherever you are and
we're gonna take questions maybe I'll
ask you guys some things who knows some
live interviews maybe some celebs will
join or YouTube people will join as well
but I love the idea of this we've had
this disability to do this thing on
skype sort of a live Colin thing for a
while but it's only gonna be people that
are community members at Rubin
report.com any plans to stop a Buffalo
later this year or on the tour we wanted
to get Buffalo in I don't think it
worked out this time Boston was the
other one that we had a theater but then
I had to change a date because of
something else so yes we are gonna add
things as I said earlier Florida I was
just down there I met a gajillion people
everywhere I went so yes we're gonna add
a whole bunch of Florida stuff
the Canada stuff as I said we're working
on a separate Australian tour which I'm
hoping is gonna happen in July so we're
piecing this thing together but if
you're in Milwaukee I guess your closest
bet is right now is New York City which
is a bit of a bit of a trek but I I did
that Trek a few times my brother went to
SUNY Buffalo I went to SUNY Binghamton
will you be coming to Milwaukee later
this year I remember you telling me in
person that you would be visiting on the
book tour so there isn't a Milwaukee
stop yet but again we've got some some
stuff in as the pundits call it middle
America hopefully maybe you can jump to
one of the other spots that are not not
too far from you
but then hopefully will be will be
adding on more let's see a bunch of you
guys have asked about Vegas I don't know
that Vegas even came up as like a real
tour stop on this thing I will find out
about that let's see uh here's a good
one how's Jordan doing have you talked
to him so obviously I don't want to
share anything private that's between me
and Jordan more between me and his
family or whatever else I will tell you
this I saw Jordan right before
Thanksgiving he was doing better than
he's doing even better now he's gonna be
back soon you know he was very open
about taking this mild klonopin I think
it was he would talk about it sometimes
on stage during the tour his wife got
got very ill they thought she had
terminal cancer I was actually with him
out to lunch when he got the phone call
about that he plowed through and never
stopped never second-guessed himself
just kept going and going and going
his wife Tammy who's a wonderful lady
she was on tour with us for most of it
until she had to start taking some tests
you know I can't share anything really
that's that's the private stuff I do in
the book I write about a lot of my
experience being on tour with Jordan and
the way he influenced me and changed me
on some things that you guys know about
he will be back soon and I can I can
tell you that and and we need him it
feels like there's a little hole in the
internet right now doesn't it there
definitely feels it feels like there's
something as the Democrats self-destruct
how important is it that Republicans do
some quality control and actually elect
people who reduce the size of government
and preserve Liberty I mean I love this
question and I think this is this is the
great question right now like everyone
knows that the Democrats are imploding
the idea that a party has Bernie Sanders
the socialist communist whatever he is
at this point big government you know
it's never enough government guy and
Elizabeth Warren who's pretty much the
same plus you got to throw in even even
more intersectionality and I'm gonna
have a trans person her higher the head
of trans issues at the Department of
trans I mean it's all nonsense right
that these people are in the same party
is Mike Bloomberg and and Joe Biden
who are I would say sort of more
old-school liberals right there sort of
centrist Democrats even though they're
probably too left for what I like or
what I believe in at this point let's
say these people have nothing to do with
each other and the party needs to split
it needs to split a OSI who I think is
wrong about everything she actually said
that a couple weeks ago that these
people shouldn't be in the same party
and they shouldn't the socialists should
have their party take all of your
absolutely time-tested terrible ideas
and get out of the way do your thing and
then there should be an adult table for
for decent Democrats that perhaps want
more government than I want but that
have a basically decent set of ideas and
then there should be a conservative
Republican set of ideas and a
libertarian push on poll on how to make
more Liberty out of that set of ideas
and everything else but I do think the
party does not survive this thing I do
not think that the Democratic Party I'm
not saying the Democratic Party won't
exist but he will either truly split in
two and we will have a socialist party
and I've been saying it for years
they're only calling them democratic
socialists for now that's just a
temporary thing until you crush the
Democratic part because socialism is not
about democracy which is the funniest
part by the way when Bernie at the
debates he always talks about the
authoritarian government jobs really
while at the same time he loves all of
these countries but he doesn't realize
that his policies are all authoritarian
every authoritarian means the government
does it the power outside of the people
does it bernie is the biggest
authoritarian there is so he's screaming
about Trump but it's like Trump has kept
the wheels on the system you can say
whatever you want about Trump nobody
comes knocking at your door the second
Trump tweets that was in blue check
journalists tell him to go [ __ ] himself
and whatever else and it's like nobody's
coming for you guys everything
everything's okay try to imagine it the
other way when Bernie's president and
now he's got the media behind him and
all the lefties and the crush on free
speech that will come with that and then
you think that it'll be okay for
conservatives who are all labeled Nazis
to say bad things about Dear Leader
Bernie they will gladly change rules and
laws to stifle that's the plus big tech
and everything else so there is a
complete disconnect between what
authoritarian is from birdie bootie
realism and what actual authoritarian
and is what authoritarianism actually is
let's put it that way
but the parties do need to split but to
answer your question directly what I
would love to see now and this is what I
see and what I have been talking about
for years conservatives and broadly
people on the right whether you're a
classical liberal so you maybe want a
little more government than say a
conservative does or you're a little
more liberal socially perhaps on
something like abortion than a
traditional conservative classical
liberals conservatives libertarians
people that actually believe in the
Liberty that believe in individual
rights meaning everyone has the same
rules applied to everybody right this is
the basic core of of the American
experiment I see an incredible amount of
people coming together arguing about
this stuff sitting down to agree to
disagree
pro-choice but grudgingly I actually
explained my position very thoroughly in
the book ben shapiro is not yet we can
have a conversation decently or debt or
dennis prager is now we can have a
respectful conversation this simply does
not happen on the other side a great
example of this two weeks ago I had
Heather McDonald on the first question I
asked Heather McDonald who's a fellow at
the Manhattan Institute she considers
herself a secular conservative she's
been secular her whole life she's been
conservative her whole life doesn't
believe in God but she believes that
there is room for secular conservatism
within the conservative movement I agree
with her that there should be for sure
that being said I do agree more with I
would say the Jordan Peterson argument
that there has to be an undergirding of
belief that set up our enlightenment
values that that's a whole other topic
at the topic I love and I get into in
the book as well but her argument is
there should be a secular belief a
secular room for consume for secular
conservatives sorry Dennis Prager
watched our video and she references
Dennis Prager --zz belief system a few
times and he didn't attack her over it
he didn't slam her he didn't try to deep
platform her you know what he did you're
not gonna believe this guy's not gonna
believe this he heard someone say some
things about his beliefs he brought him
he wrote a piece online a respectful
piece about two people he said he liked
in conversation and his disagreements
with them and then I shared that piece
and that's exactly what I see happening
on the right right now that simply
doesn't happen on the left purges
everybody that disagrees with them they
constantly try to throw anyone under the
bus that that doesn't agree with every
part and there there is a fundamental
a reason for that and the fundamental
reason for that I believe is that people
basically on the right and again the
right left thing it's all these things
are becoming a morphus terms that don't
mean as much but generally speaking if
you're on the right you believe in
individual rights if you're on the left
right now it's very unclear what the
unifying principle is so you individual
rights it's very easy to explain what
that is you believe that every single
citizen of a country should have the
exact same rights they no one should be
treated differently because of their
color or their gender or their sexuality
or anything else this is a fundamental
part of being right being on the right
and you know sometimes they fail at it
by the way they do right gay marriage
took a lot longer than it should have
from a conservative or a right
perspective the left doesn't really have
a unifying principle anymore it has this
idea that government should sort of do
stuff and that everyone that doesn't
kind of believe that is racist and a
capitalism is sort of evil but there's
no underlying principle is a group
rights is it individual rights it's very
unclear what that is so it's what
everyone sort of feels at every any
given moment so that's why when you
watch the debates last night they're all
yelling at each other and speaking over
each other and you're going what the
hell is Bernie Sanders doing at the same
debate that Mike Bloomberg that these
guys are diametrically opposed
I mean Bloomberg doesn't hate the United
States Bernie hates the United States I
really believe that they never say any
deliberately do they ever say anything
nice about the United States about the
amount of freedom that we've brought to
more people than anywhere else do they
ever talk about all the good we've done
in the world that we've brought more
people out of poverty than any other
place I mean they're afraid to say those
things Bloomberg had a an American flag
pin up there and it was like man you're
on the outs buddy or Biden the best is
when Biden who I think does get what
America is whether you agree with him or
not or whether he's having some
cognitive stuff or not vitam every now
and again talks about separation of
power in the Constitution and it's like
dude you're in the wrong room these
people don't care what do they talk
about day one I'm gonna do this day one
I'm gonna do that
that's authoritarianism Bernie that's
authoritarianism the president isn't
supposed to do all these things on day
one or on day 60 the presidents was to
sign things into law and by the way they
all fail at this they all use executive
actions and I've been critical of Trump
when he's done it and I was critical
over Obama when I did it and I was
critical of George W Bush me he did it
in etc etc but what we're seeing right
now
it's just a real ideological juggle it's
like it's like a you know like one of
those machines like that you go it looks
like a game show thing in like the 70s
or 80s and there's money flying around
you're just grabbing whatever that's
sort of what's happened I left there
just grabbing whatever they can on any
given moment and when you do that well
then this the guy who did it a little
differently automatically has to be the
bad guy so I do think it is on
right-leaning people conservatives
libertarians whatever else - right now
go you know we've got a little momentum
right now we seem to have a little
cohesion how do we then rein in the
spending how do we actually do the
things we say we're gonna do because
often yes which is the heart of your
question which was asked at 18 minutes
ago they often talk about you know
cutting spending and the rest of it and
then they don't do it when they're
office so I do think there's a real
interesting opportunity right now for
for people on the right to do that and I
will say one other thing you know when
you talk about the split between the
Bernese and the Bloomberg's and and what
the mess I mean the abject debacle that
is the the Democratic Party right now
well you could say well wait a minute
Dave four years ago when the Republicans
running you had Cruz and Cruz hated
Trump but now he likes Trump and you had
Rubio who hated Trump but now he likes
Trump The Trews hate they hate but this
guy and this guy
that's true but all of that stuff was
basically personality driven right it
was like people didn't like Trump's
personality he didn't like their
personalities that sort thing but they
had a sort of basic set of beliefs that
were right they believed in capitalism
right they basically believed in
individual rights they basically believe
that the American experiment is a good
experiment etc etcetera so there is a
cohesion there the personalities may not
match and they may disagree on things
but that's what a political party or a
set of beliefs is supposed to contain
with right it's supposed to grapple with
those things the left has just gone off
the deep end with those things that is a
huge fundamental difference so that's
where they're at what are we doing
people that don't burn this book tour
has been announced this morning presale
tickets are open right now you got to
use code solo if you click the Live
Nation link that is right there in
YouTube so I know you see it I can see
you right now because you've got a
webcam and we can see you you click that
Live Nation link enter code solo we've
got 17 stops booked already if you buy a
ticket today
and you forward your receipt over to
support a true band report com we're
also going to give you a month
free access to Ruben report.com where
you can check out the community we've
got a ton of great stuff going on over
there there's no BOTS there's no trolls
we have real people having real
conversations ad free video we don't
save your data we're spinning off these
communities to other people we got major
people coming on over the next couple
weeks lots of good stuff happening okay
um let's see um whoo let's see this is
this is sort of funny Dave like your
folks I also live in a Florida condo you
described their condo as little my condo
is two-bedroom two-bath at a very modest
1,200 square feet can you define little
for us well I said that's a good
question I don't know how many square
feet it is but I can tell you the condos
got a little kitchen you know you can
get like four people maybe in the
kitchen kind of cook I can tell you this
David was trying to cook for everybody
and another person got in the kitchen he
was like I have no room here so he's got
a little kitchen or he got a little
kitchen there you have two bedrooms that
have queen-size beds and little
nightstands but not much room to operate
beyond that little hallway you have a
look you know a little front balcony a
little back balcony and you have a you
know a decent sized living room so I
don't know what I guess maybe about 1200
square feet even that seems a little big
to me I'm not sure but that is
interesting it's an interesting thought
and one of the things that I was
thinking about is you know I live here
in LA you know our property taxes are
bananas and real estate is insane here
and everyone know everywhere I go people
why are you living there and all the
weather's nice but it's not just that
the weather is nice it's that this you
know la does have an interesting thing
happening right now which is that as
politics and media collide
la in many ways is becoming the home of
politics you know Shapiro is right here
Prager is right here Peter teal has
moved down here there's an interesting
sort of alignment of say right-leaning
people in in LA right now where DC it's
like DC has lost a lot of momentum you
know Trump is sort of drain the swamp at
some level right whether you like them
or not
and the endless DC punditry you know
these people that get everything wrong
year after year after year they're
becoming increasingly irrelevant and not
that you can judge everything by
by retweets or or traction online but
even yesterday I was looking at
something
the New York Times tweeted out something
and I just thought it was so stupid and
I looked at the numbers and it's like
you know it has 12 retweets and 15 likes
and three comments and it's like you can
don't have to make this about me but you
could look at my tweets from the debate
last night and I have things with 10,000
retweets you know 15,000 likes let's
cetera et cetera and it's like I think
just people are paying attention to
things in very very different ways so to
relate that back to to Florida
everything else I could definitely see
myself living in Florida in the future I
love Florida I could see a Texas
situation I don't think my long-term
future is in the People's Republic of
California any new updates coming with
locals any new features etc yeah we have
a ton of new features so just in the
last week our most recent update you can
now follow other people so you can get
push notifications from other people so
if there's someone in the community that
you like maybe I like them more than me
you can get push notifications to your
phone every time they post you can now
bookmark posts we're working on a
seriously great content catalog where
you'll be able to see every video that
we've ever put up every audio podcast
and the rest of it we're working on some
really cool decentralization stuff
related to that I should tell you that
as I mentioned earlier I'm going to San
Francisco tomorrow for a couple days of
fundraising there so we're doing our
next round of fundraising we have three
investors right now by the way and
locals I've told some of these before
three investors all who were fans of
mine who I met over the years and we
raised about 600 grand by the way I take
none of that money one I do not take a
dime I've put money in a tremendous
amount of time into locals I don't take
any salary you know if we blow this
thing up and it sells and keeps growing
and growing I'll do fine but I believe
in the mission and what we're doing here
and actually like they're something kind
of fun about like building something
that's in line with your beliefs and the
rest of it which I guess is what I've
done here with the show as well so we
have we have all sorts of new features
coming there's going to be live
streaming a whole bunch of stuff it's
all coming we opened up our first office
in Europe we've got about 12 full timers
over there we have an office in New York
good stuffs happening and and by the way
since we are raising funds if you are an
angel investor or
or even a small VC because we don't want
big VC money I don't want really big big
tech money we are raising funds right
now so feel free to pitch us on what
you're doing or send us an email and
we'll pitch you but it's all happening
within the next couple weeks a bunch of
investors have the docs
you could have send an email to contact
at rubin report comm if you're
interested in by the way I know a few of
you some of you who I know are even
watching this right now our fans who are
investors so it's just it's just cool
we're building something cool cancelled
Netflix today to support more locals and
other content creators stop feeding the
beast and it will die that is it my
friend thank you very much I mean that I
really do believe that look that the one
way we can get big tech to change that
we can get anything changes is change
your behaviors right we all we can't
everyone's screaming you know I think I
told this once before on a live stream
but I went into Susan with Jess keys
office she's the YouTube CEO I don't
think she was thrilled to meet with me
but enough public pressure had applied
been applied so she had some even she
didn't take a picture with me she takes
a picture with all the other youtubers
no picture it's okay Susan and she seems
perfectly fine and I'm in there and
they've got the head of PR and the first
thing they say is this is off the record
so blah blah I'm not gonna repeat
anything that was said but I will say
one thing that I said which was I said
Susan you know you got a lot of people
right now you got Elizabeth Warren on
the Left calling for big tech to be
regulated you got Tucker Carlson on the
right calling for big tech to be
regulated I'm probably the last guy he
was gonna come in here and say I don't
want it to be big regulated so you might
want to work with me I can't repeat what
we said after that but that was another
one of those moments where I was like I
have to build this thing for myself so
all of us we have to just change our
behaviors you know they gave us all of
this stuff for free they gave us Twitter
for free and Facebook for free and
YouTube for free and everything else for
free and what did what did we have to do
for it we had to sell our soul like Bart
Simpson in season four right we had to
sell our soul and I think there's a much
better mature way to do an Internet it's
gonna cost you a couple bucks by the way
the next thing with locals because
people keep asking me is so let's say we
have now 20 30 locals creators and you
really like a whole bunch of these
people but you don't want to give
everybody five bucks cuz you got 30
people at five bucks 150 bucks a month
it's like buying cable in the old days
well what's gonna happen is some
big-name creators are gonna start
building out their network so let's say
I'm in my network right and now I also
have Bridgette fantasies community in
mind who I love
Mikell malice who i think is great and a
whole bunch of other people i think is
great well now you could subscribe to my
network let's say it's 20 bucks a month
and they all get a smaller portion of
that I get more of it let's say if I'm
the bigger name in it and maybe there's
a network that has a bigger name than me
and there's all sorts of interesting
ways to monetize these things and do
these things so we're doing what I think
is front
edie internet stuff to fix the mess and
get rid of the bots and the trolls and
everything else and I hope you'll join
us and by the way if you want to get
into Rubin report comm for free or the
iOS app or the the Google Play app if
you want to just see what I'm doing
there instead of me just talking about
it I'll give you a month for free right
now all you gotta do is buy a ticket to
the tour so you go to Live Nation calm
the links right down there enter code
solo pick your local tour forward us the
receipt contact that Reuben report.com
and and we'll give you a free month
access and fiddle around see what you
like and if you don't like it head on
head on out partner and if you do like
it we'll see what happens woo
why isn't Elizabeth Warren going on and
going after Bernie like all the other
candidates great question
and something struck me is very obvious
last night related to that so Elizabeth
knows she's done right the her and
Bernie are basically the same thing
she's like a more wonky they're both
deeply unlikable I think but she's sort
of a more wonky version she knows she's
out but what's she playing for here
she's playing for a chance to get in at
Bernie administration now maybe that
means she wants to be be VP or maybe
it's bizarre of intersectionality who
knows what it is that she wants to be
but if you saw the way she was going
after Bloomberg last night and then she
lays off Bernie you know once in a while
she'll say something about Bernie like
oh I like your plans but I do it this
way okay that's fine but she's really
going as Bernie's attack dog because she
knows bloom Bloomberg is the threat to
Bernie right because Bloomberg is the
established order threat to the
socialist I don't like either one of
them but that's her move and and if you
want some sort of evidence of that
remember back to 2016 do you remember
the debate when there seemed to be a
little movement for Rubio Rubio was kind
of on the way up Trump was Trump was
above it the whole time right he was
running always ahead but Rubio was kind
of moving up and then there's a debate
where Christie who was not doing well
very comparable to Elizabeth Warren
people kind of knew his name but didn't
major support Christie just went in and
um demolished Rubio and then it was done
Rubio was out a couple days later and I
sense that's what Warren's doing here
there's a there's a handshake nod Warren
realized after that debate where she
tried to cut Bernie down that it's not
gonna work so now she wants in on the
administration so the best thing she can
do to show loyalty cuz it's all a game
right politics is a big game is take out
Bloomberg that that's what she's doing
over there so III think you know she's
done after Super Tuesday this thing goes
down to you know we'll see what happens
in South Carolina but you know basically
it's like it's Bernie obviously he's got
the rabid base by the way you never won
saying oh this means socialism is coming
to America this means communism this is
a rabid group of you know really hostile
angry off in college kids but very
confused people that I don't think this
plays well I mean Trump is probably
praying that Bernie wins because Trump
will then win in an absolute landslide
because I think most decent people like
America and all Trump's can have to do
is just basically do like you know I
like America and Bernie's gonna be
screaming about and it's just not gonna
fly so I think Bernie wants I'm sorry I
think Trump wants Bernie more than more
than Bloomberg for sure but I think what
happens here is you end up with the
final three being being Biden short of
you know the Biden thing it's sad it's
like I don't want to talk about him cuz
it's said I mean watching the guy be
virtually unable to finish a sentence
coherently and last night he said what
was the thing he said 170 million
Americans have been killed by guns since
2007 and no one even called him out on
stage on it because it's because it's
sad to watch right it's like why doesn't
someone pull him aside and say Joe you
can go out to pasture now it's ok you
you you were a vice president you were a
senator for 20-plus years like you can
relax man I mean he's caught off as
angry and you can feel it that he's
losing it and it's sad actually but I
think it'll probably be him and
Bloomberg cuz he's just got the money
and Bernie who's got the momentum and
then it's like you know mayor Pete is
just kind of nothing he just strikes me
as so inauthentic like he's just like
stands in a mirror all day long saying
I'm Obama
I'm Obama that thing has passed
Klobuchar I think is decent Klobuchar
seems to like America which is a weird
position as a Democrat
but like I don't think the energy is
behind a moderate right now so she's
kind of out of the way and steyr isn't
worth talking about so there you go is
there a story behind the code solo is it
a Star Wars reference I didn't come up
with that but the first thing I thought
they said we'll do code solo I don't
know if maybe they did it and honor star
works for me but it was the first thing
that popped in my line so solo if you
click that link right down there for
live nation 17 tour stops enter code
solo you get VIP tickets you can get
preferred seating and get general access
I'll meet with you after the show
I'll do you know what I'll do the quick
the quick run-through again New York
City Gramercy Theater April 28th theater
of the Living Arts in Philly on April
29th
then we're in Dallas at the House of
Blues Glenn Beck will be joining me for
that one on May 3rd May 4th through then
we're in where are we there Houston
Texas
on may 5th we're at the Aztec Theater in
San Antonio May 7th we're in Cincinnati
Ohio May 8th we're in Cleveland May 9th
were at the old National Center in
Indianapolis May 10th were at the
varsity theater in Minneapolis May
eleventh were at the Monroe live in
Grand Rapids May 12th were in Detroit
Michigan at the st. Andrews Hall oh
sorry
there were more here that I skipped
before May 15th were at the summit in
Denver out of the summit that's cool
may one day may night eighteenth where
at the House of Blues in Anaheim
California I think I know who I have for
that show that's our local LA show you
might want to attend that one if you're
in a local la area on may 19th were at
the Palace of Fine Arts in San Francisco
May twentieth were in Seattle Washington
at the Neptune theatre and May 21st
Peter Bogosian will be joining me in
Portland Oregon on May 21st that was oh
and I skipped that Silver Spring one
again which is the DC show christina
hoff sommers the factual feminist will
be joining me for that one there we go
all right a couple more questions here
man you guys you guys are blowing me up
today alright let's see I want to make
sure I understand how this works
correctly you live stream on YouTube but
we use the app to leave posting comments
yes exactly and because I saw this we
know that that works because there's no
other place to leave comments people
might be commenting on my Twitter right
now or Facebook or whatever but I'm only
listening and talking to you guys
um let's see this is an interesting one
curious why Jordan went one way and you
and other on launching the patreon
alternative local seems much more
community focus but I haven't really
studied this want to be completely
completely completely completely clear
and transparent on this first up there
is absolutely no tension between Jordan
and I Jordan knew that I was working on
an app originally we sort of had the
same starting point and we would and he
said to me many times he's like you
should be working on self ihb we're
gonna stuff let's see what kind of works
out and maybe we can work these things
two things together I think ultimately
there is a lot of movement and ability
for locals and things spot to work
together
my personal belief was I wanted to build
something that worked for me first
because I'm so in the center of sort of
the creator element of this as an online
creator and as a free speech guy and I
thought if I could build something for
myself first I could help build it for
other people and Jordan was doing more
of a platform thing but then also as
Jordan had some of the health problems
he sort of stepped away and my feeling
was if I was gonna be involved in
something I needed to deeply be involved
in it at the granular level from day one
so that's really the only answer I hope
both of them become huge huge huge
successes maybe they become one thing
maybe there are two things maybe they
are competition
none of that would affect our friendship
or our ability to work with each other
so it is totally all good and I
appreciate the question are you gonna
continue doing Rubin report during the
tour so I do have a couple off days in
May and I'll come home and we'll try to
tape stuff we may tape some some live
stuff on the road I was thinking about
maybe just doing a live show at the bar
with you guys where I'll just will take
over a bar one night and I'll just bring
on people alive and we'll get drunk and
stupid and see what happens so we're
gonna do all sorts of stuff let's see
just watch the Veritas video my goodness
how does America know about what
mainstream media is up to if they refuse
to talk about it themselves so I haven't
seen today's Veritas video but I guess
there was somebody at ABC who says he's
a socialist and that they were sort of
suppressing news or something like that
I can't comment on it specifically cuz I
haven't seen it yet but I can tell you
this and this is what much of the book
is about nothing really surprises me
anymore right like we've seen it guys
we've seen it the New York Times did a
cover story on how YouTube radicalizes
people to the far right and in that
story on the online version I was on the
front and this one they held me to like
the third page but a huge picture of my
face with something to the effect of the
you know the creator's leading people to
the far right or it might have even said
all right my dad has been a subscriber
to the New York Times as a New York
liberal good liberal for over 40 years
before I was born and he had to go to
the coffee store shop that morning that
Sunday to see that and have a friend
come to him saying oh I don't know your
Sunday but was all right I mean it's
nonsense it's drivel by the way the guy
who wrote it his his name is Kevin Roos
he's a whole thing's a ruse I'll tell
you that much but he's a New York Times
writer I invited him on the show and of
course he declined and it's like these
are not good people the the journalists
the journalists who just try to assess
and have assassinated everybody are not
good people and that's why they're
constantly attacking everybody who
doesn't fit the narrative and oh well
this is this is a good little teaser -
on April 27th the day before the book
comes out my next Prager you video is
coming out and this is exactly what it's
on it's that we have what I believe is a
bravery deficit in the United States we
have people that are afraid to say what
they think and it's not because they're
Nazis or bigots it's because they're
good decent people and we have an
immediate elite class that is trying to
confuse and conflate a million different
issues so that we're all afraid to say
anything out of fear of losing our job
or losing a relationship or the other
thing we got to stop cow a cow into it
we got to start fighting it and I hope
you will join me on that mission and
there you go
is there a secular conservative Church I
might join you no one that agrees with
six of the Ten Commandments I have to
look at the six you're interested in I
mean the do not
murder thing seems pretty good the covet
thy neighbor's wife I mean I guess he
could covet her you can't covet her to
the point that you're throwing her the
basement and given her a lotion in the
basket sort of thing but that's that's
an interesting one good question any
class tonight to write another book in
the future I think so I've got a couple
good ideas actually some are that are
sort of more on the fun side and some
that are more on the idea side I think
the next one will be definitely more on
the fun side for sure you know partly
there partly is related to how well this
book sells although I know we've sold a
ton already and it's gonna do real well
I hear from what I understand from my
guys the penguin Random House the
bookstore so Barnes and Oban everything
else they're buying in tons of copies
Costco I was told which is cutting down
I guess on on book sales now they've
bought a time because they think it's
gonna play real well there so you know I
want to get this one out of the way and
it did take did take it took a lot of
work and a lot of time and everything
else but it was a fun process and it was
also like it helped me in terms of a
certain amount of discipline I think in
my life and also lost a little weight
while writing the book because I would
usually start writing about 8:00 a.m.
I'd wake up I usually wake up about 7:15
or so I check emails for a little bit
I'd start writing about 8:00 a.m. and I
often would just write write write write
write I write till I couldn't go any
more I'm working through the ideas where
I'm talking Pete to people about
different things and the ideas and
skyping with people trying to trying to
figure out exactly what I want to say
and then I'd realize it was 2 o'clock
and I hadn't eaten so I end up losing
some weight there and the whole thing -
what lightsaber color would you pick and
what would be your best to force ability
if you were a Jedi what lightsaber color
would I pick you know I always liked
that green the luke green from Return of
the Jedi
that was always a good color because he
was a little more of a badass - he
wasn't just purely blue good right
obi-wan blue good he was a little more
badass in that one my power I think
would be not forcing people to say
something but allowing them to say what
they think what do you think about that
how do we get backstage tickets so we're
doing VIP meet and greets where I will
so first of if you buy the VIP seat you
get preferred seating so you're in the
first couple rows and then immediately
the show I take about a five-minute
break and then I'm gonna come out give a
small talk to as many people as buy
those tickets there's you know we shake
your hands I'll sign the books the whole
thing so just buy a VIP ticket and you
will meet me you will shake my hand and
all that good stuff handshaking to be
announced though obviously with
coronavirus and all we've got to be
careful about that let's see I'll do one
or two more and then and then we'll do a
quick reset let's see I've been thinking
a lot lately about how the core conflict
in the country right now is it necessary
left first right but authoritarian
versus libertarian and how those that
are leaving the left are simply refusing
to play the authoritarian left's game
wonder if you agree with this or see it
differently yeah yeah I think you're
basically right that's why the right
left thing it's it's very confusing now
especially as more and more of you get
your news from YouTube and Twitter and
online places because the definition of
these things is different a liberal in
the UK is more of my kind of liberal
right then say what is thought of as a
liberal in the United States so the
left/right is confusing so basically
what you're saying here is you either
believe in top-down authoritarianism
meaning that the government somehow is
inherently good and knows what to do and
is gonna do the right thing for the most
amount of people that would I would say
is authoritarian and by the way it
doesn't mean that everyone that believes
that is evil I think the road to hell is
paved with good intentions I think
they're just confused about what human
nature is especially human nature of
groups or you have the more libertarian
view not meaning that you're a pure
libertarian or part of the libertarian
party but you basically believe that
individual people know what's best for
them you person watching this you
probably have a better idea on how to
live your life than I know how to live
your life and that from there if we
could just treat everybody equally that
that gives the most chance of prosperity
to grow and then within that is there
are arguments about where traditional
conservatives are say more religious
than say traditional libertarians a
classical liberal may want a tiny bit
more government than a pure libertarian
a libertarian may may want a little more
government for some reason than ancap I
mean all of those things sort of fit
within that scope but I think the basic
premise that you're laying out there is
correct and and that's by the way is why
I'm so enthused about what's going on
here you know I saw a tweet by that
clown on CNN brian Stelter who's wrong
about everything and you know
just not good but it was something like
a week or two ago something about like
how everyone's so upset about politics
and everything so horrible we all just
need a break and it's like I get that I
mean I get why it's all kind of sucky
but it's like there's something so great
down here if you if you just come in
look for it and that's why the
Democratic debates are so depressing
because the only way that their ideas of
more government and taking from some and
giving to others make sense is if
everything is bad here which is why they
make you feel like everyone is racist
and everything is evil in the United
States is awful and capitalism is
terrible but we all know that's actually
not true right why there's a reason
Bernie hasn't left this American
wasteland for Denmark yet and guess what
they wouldn't be thrilled if Bernie did
go to Denmark the Danish would not be
that thrilled so but they prey on the
idea that that you they can keep you
thinking everything's horrible that
something's coming for you that
something evil is out there and I'm not
saying bad ideas can't flourish of
course they can of course they can but
again if you're in the United States and
2020 you got it pretty good and that
doesn't mean it can't be better but you
but you should be trying for is change
things on the margin the way you can
make things a little bit better perhaps
in your own local community my local
congressman by the way he lives about a
mile away from here his office is over
there I've stopped in there he wasn't
there but I actually stopped in you can
do that you can do that too I've got
this fricking this is California it's a
disaster LA but there's a whole bunch of
garbage at my this the the highway stop
right here my highway exit and it's like
well what I have to do is deal with the
local government to clean that up not
hand everything over to the federal
government cuz then nothing's ever gonna
get better so I I'm very enthused right
now I think a lot of good stuff is
happening another good thing that's
happening by the way is don't burn this
book which is my first book it's coming
out on April 28th you can buy it on
Amazon or you can buy it on Barnes and
noble.com wherever else or burn don't
burn this book humbly I've got links to
the book but the tour ladies and jelly
spoons ladles and jellies please I
should say the tour was announced today
it is on presale if you use code so low
in honor of Han Solo apparently you can
buy tickets today and if you buy a
ticket and you forward your
/ to contact at Rubin report.com we're
gonna give you one month for free at
Rubin report.com which you can also get
an iOS app for or a Google Android
Google Play Store for Android and check
out our community will give you a month
free there and meet and greet and all
that good stuff and I hope to see you
guys there
I will take two more questions I'll do
one more promo and then we're good
do we do I have closed liberal friends I
would say actually it's a good question
so here's what I could say so most of my
friend like my lifelong friends I would
say are mostly old school liberals like
me most of my friends growing up I was
always sort of into politics I remember
being in seventh eighth grade we had a
mock election in my class this was when
when I really got into politics the
first time and we had to like run a fake
campaign and it was when Dukakis was
running against George HW Bush and I was
on Dukakis aside and he was a liberal
and a Democrat I thought he was a good
guy and George Bush was four he hated
poor people and he loved war and he was
a capitalist all that factory setting
nonsense that were just fed but I always
loved politics since then and my friends
my two best friends actually right now
in my life right now are my two best
friends from childhood one of them John
who I met when I was four years old I
remember meeting him the first day of
kindergarten literally remember meeting
him and we've been best friends for
almost 40 years and our he who moved to
town when I was in third grade and I've
been fighting and arguing with these
guys about politics for years and years
and years and we still get along and we
play video games when we see each other
and can shoot hoops or whatever else
we're doing so I would say most of my
friends are liberals in that sense but I
think what you mean here is are you
friends with any leftists I truly I've
had a harder time maintaining
friendships with leftists but it it I
can tell you it's honestly as I could
possibly tell you something from my
perspective it has not been from me I
have had people that that I've known my
whole life to then watch my show or see
my Twitter or see someone that I talked
to that then think you know all sorts of
horrible things about me and then I'll
say to them well you have you ever heard
me say anything racist that's not the
point well do you think that I'm racist
well that's not the point you know the
series of things that you guys have been
I've gone through like if you're sitting
at home watching Fox News and you feel
like you have to change the channel
because you're taller and sister's
coming in or something like that it's
like we're all going through some
version of this so I guess I look I
progressives in my family I just spent a
week with with 13 family members
although some of them were very young oh
wait I got it something really funny to
tell you about that but arguing about
politics my mom and I don't quite see
eye-to-eye on this stuff but we we hug
it out at the end we always hug it out
at the end and she's moved me in some
ways and I've moved her in some ways and
I write about this very extensively in
the book actually that in my family
growing up at every holiday we'd have
huge tables 30 40 people whatever
holiday it was yelling and arguing often
about politics
who's pro-life who's pro-choice this
that the other thing and then everybody
dessert would be served and everybody
would be okay and that's the way it used
to be and that's what I want to try to
bring back it's what I've tried to do
here and I probably fail out a bit on
Twitter but I want to but I do want to
say one other thing which is I watched
the debate the other night not last
night's debate the one good got there
every four days now watch the one four
or five days ago with my two nieces one
just turned five one six said with my
nephew who is 10 and watching the debate
with this kid was absolutely hilarious
because you know you see all these blue
check people on Twitter that are like
I'm sitting here with my 11 year old son
and he wonders why a flat tax at 18% is
better than a or I'm sitting here with
my six-year-old daughter and she thinks
climate change is gonna and it's like
you guys are all making up this nonsense
you're using your kids as a as a crud
jewel to control people i sat here with
this kid he was hilarious cuz he's
asking things the kids would ask
Elizabeth Warren started a couple days
ago saying something about how she heard
somebody lost their car Baba and he's
asked me wait that woman doesn't have a
car why doesn't she have why doesn't the
woman in the purple dress have a car
what happened to her and she has
diabetes how'd she get that and what's
diabetes hey Baba I asked him I have a
tweet about this from a couple years ago
I asked him when he was like eight years
old I said what do you think about
Donald Trump I said if I say Donald
Trump to you what comes to mind he goes
he goes he's got he's orange he's got
bad hair and wears a big red tie like
that's what a kid says not this dribble
that they're always pushing on you
nonsense all right I see a whole bunch
more here one more here and then and
then I'll just push one more time for
what we're doing and then we will go
from there
is it possible to have
conversations about complex political
topics on social media most of the ones
I see involve the liberal and
conservative telling each other that
they're brainwash me neither seems to
one to actually read and understand each
other's comments it's very difficult
which is partly why we started locals
and why I think what we're building and
you're writing this to me at the Rubin
of our community I'm seeing a tremendous
amount of respectful conversation there
and I think partly that's because there
aren't a zillion burner free accounts
you got to pay a couple bucks to get in
so you treated a little bit differently
right there's a reason you watch Netflix
shows you've paid for it or your mom
paid for it you borrowed her password
although I do pay for my own Netflix
when when you have a little skin in the
game you behave a little bit better you
know but there is something else that's
a problem with this which is that you
know we're in the nascent period we're
now in a slight maturation of it but
we're in a pretty early period of the
internet we all got in for free we all
got on Facebook and all these things and
we didn't know what we were doing on
there and you start friending oh my god
I knew that guy 20 years ago in I bet
that girl in a bar the other day and
this one I had a share of this with them
and next thing you know your feed I
don't even have facebook anymore I have
a fan page which I don't even manage I
literally never look at Facebook it's
not on my phone I don't see it anymore
but you have a feed on Facebook I see it
sometimes when I'm on a plane somebody's
next to me with their iPads scrolling
and it looks insane cuz it's like
picture of meny picture of Trump
terrorist attack cartoon sports game and
it's like you're looking at it and your
brain is going like just like hate but
and then your emotions actually get out
of whack I suddenly you hate your
brother you love the stranger you want
to kill this person this person to not
say like it's all bananas so I think
what's gonna be the next version of all
of this is that we are going to become
more local we're gonna start doing
smaller groups by the way I know that
I'm Way ahead of the game on locals calm
because Facebook is promoting groups all
the time now and the thing is with
Facebook is you guys created the problem
no one wants you to solve the problem
you've already got everybody's data
game's up for you get out of the way I
don't need to give big tech to govern
you I don't need you to by locals we're
just gonna create something good so I'm
trying I'm trying the best I can and if
you want in for free at Rubin report
calm which is the first project of
locals although we've got Bridgette
fantasies community we've got Michael
Mouse's community we've got carpi Dom's
community we've got a whole bunch
is coming including next week I think
we're gonna announce maybe in two weeks
somebody that actually will completely
change the game altogether I think you
will be quite shocked to at some of the
people were signing up to this thing and
they will create their networks and
we're gonna clean up the internet and
it's gonna be pretty cool if you want in
for free
buy a ticket to don't burn this book
tour which the link is right down below
use code solo and just forward that
receipt the ticket receipt over to
contact at Reuben report comm and we're
gonna be a month for you over there all
right people I've been talking all day
long and I plenty more talking to do so
that's it for me for now thank you guys
as always I'm super psyched to get the
book out there I'm psyched to get on
tour meet you guys talk to you guys
continue this whole thing lots of good
stuff is happening and I hope you guys
feel it I know it can feel crazy
sometimes but I hope you feel the basic
goodness that is out there so I thank
you for watching oh and by the way if
you're if you're watching this live
you've heard me repeat it a million
times
but until midnight tonight we'll honor
midnight tonight tonight is February 26
so at midnight tonight Pacific time we
will honor the code to give you the
month for free so then after that if you
end up watching this tomorrow we're not
going to give you the month free at the
community anymore but until midnight
tonight if you buy a ticket to the tour
and you forward to Connecticut
Reuben port comm we're gonna give you a
month free Reuben report.com that is all
for me I need a drink
goodbye